even just recently john hopkins noted
that
73 74 of the people who died from covert
were obese
if we had a system in place government
politics
health care which is not health care
it's sick care it's got nothing to do
with health doctors are
experts in pathology and pharmacology
drug dealers yeah they are literally it
is a drug
you know and a disease management system
but if we really cared for human
vitality and health
then the things we would be mandating is
that we would be mandating don't use
glyphosate don't eat gmos
you know make sure gyms stay open make
sure people understand meditation the
importance of sleep
make sure people understand the beauty
of community and having conversations
like this where we get rid of our
dysfunction and our differences
that would be where we'd spend and we
wouldn't even need the billions that
they're spending just spend a few
million to educate people
you know that that would be then an
indicator of a unity an industry that
cares about people
pharma is not celebrating each quarter
when their drug cells drop
that would be people don't need it right
that would be an indication of a
company that is dedicated to health no
that would inspire
a lot of people to probably be fired and
more ad money to be spent to try and
promote the sale of drugs they just want
to make money
it's a business we're all you know in
our own way trying to make a livelihood
but when it's under the guise of
healthcare that's when it becomes
disgusting
because it's not it's about sick care
and disease management and selling drugs
and now especially with this sort of
mandated energy that a lot of people are
rightly so
feeling defined about and resisting
because it's
going back to the feeling it might be
what someone's saying but they're
feeling like no this there's something
up here even those who
don't subscribe to conspiracy theories
whatever conspiracy theory means that's
another narrative that the media
that put out there like anti-vaxxer it's
just such a dumb statement
like what are people going to accuse me
of being like an anti-cocainer
or like i'm an anti-cancer yeah i'm an
anti-coca-cola because i don't drink it
like
all right no i'm pro-health right i'm
pro-vitality i'm pro-love i'm pro
like people like really maximizing their
own potential
so all of these statements that are
thrown out there are sadly
driven by you know these agendas and
that's just where people are at so
where am i at and is it difficult
it is but again i just keep doing what i
keep doing and i keep resonating
with whoever's ready to listen and i
keep bringing as much love as i can
even for those people who think that
they're doing the right thing and that
whatever agenda they have they need to
have more control they want to have more
money
i'm like you got billions of dollars
like seriously you need more like like
just let people live their lives and
let's
you know as cliche as it is from
whatever the la riots many
many years ago what was the expression
like can't we all just get along
so apparently we can't yet but i'm doing
whatever i can to uprise
you know people's awareness and
consciousness so that people go oh hang
on a minute
you know it looked like you were coming
from a place of caring but actually it's
self-preserving in its nature
and you're disregarding the most
important part of your life which is
yourself
and when people start to really
recognize and revere life is the word i
use like honor life you know
like yeah when i was a kid maybe i'd see
a spider and i'd kill it you know
because you don't know and i'm like
that's
a spider like i mean do i have to kill
it could i maybe put it on a piece of
paper towel and take it outside is it
that difficult
you know so it's just having a different
conversation about how we look at life
we value life
each other right now unfortunately we
live in a paradigm where there's harm of
self
you know we just saw it on camera harm
of other and harm of planet earth that
is the paradigm we live in there's
harm and abuse is normalized you know i
sort of mean today which was
it's so telling that you know he said oh
thank god my
my my son doesn't have to put up with
pepe le pew you know whatever that is
yeah like pepe le pew they just
cancelled him like again like this whole
cancelled disney thing whatever oh
that's right i just heard that there's
can't there's
all kinds of disney shows yeah so dumb
like so they canceled pepe le pew and he
said thank god that they cancelled that
but at least my son can play auto theft
or whatever thought of
he can kill someone and burn a hooker to
death because he doesn't want to pay her
like that's okay although the other one
was like you know song of the year
is cardi b or whatever her name is like
that song of the year but dr seuss is
like completely inappropriate
so that's what i deal with from a
perspective of what i would say it's
you know some pretty decent eyes yeah
it's madness
it's absolute insanity but i hold a
space and i hold for the new world the
new paradigm that people want to step
into which is more harmonious
which is a more loving which is more
based in vitality like even here we just
nudged in the right direction because
you found more love for you you found
more love and compassion for bev
yeah and that's a healing so that's what
i'm committed to i love that
and do the best well you said yourself
others and the planet right
yeah but it so it's starting if you love
yourself a little more
yeah you're gonna love the other person
a little more yeah you're gonna love the
planet
like that they all it's a it's a they
all go hand-in-hand
as they say hurt people hurt people and
that's what we're seeing right now is a
lot of hurt people who are really
hurting a lot of people you know and
it's